get start the new year with brand new
ways of torturing you by the way this is
a cute line
[Laughter]
this is a chose to work with us and I
wanted to come back here and see if you
guys wanted to help me shoot a special
thing here I'll just do it from my line
[Laughter]
hi I'm sorry weird it's not from there
oh I'm sorry
weird it made it sound I'll tell you
what critic I'll have you watch the film
that inspired me for all of this
Nutcracker in 3d well fingers illusion
is back Oh run out the window
that's rich coming from the guy who just
gets people to watch and by using
he just doesn't get it it's always more
important to be loud and mean the
killer's release their own plate in the
monster just monster just monster thank
you so much for making my vision of home
alone finally come true
thanks for inviting us to be in it
whatever
that was the last shot thank you so much
for making my vision of home alone
finally come true too late it's already
up yeah mmhmm yeah time moves faster on
the innit yeah I guess I didn't are you
gonna keep doing it
fuck no well it's good to know I don't
need to rely on it we're ready and we're
not no forgot this one thing everybody
goes through different things so they're
inspired by different things and even
those things change people places places
I don't know it's different for everyone
yeah people go through different
experiences so they experience different
things you know experience we watch this
every year on our own and this is the
first year we finally decided to watch
it all together speaking of which who's
down for just skipping the special and
going to them
you were saying something you weren't
quite expecting to see something in this
oh the zodiac oh you weren't yeah
exactly because I've been with the with
the doubt over his actual identity I
wasn't expecting him to show up
bill I'm liking alongside the Dahmer's
and the you know Bundy's and all the
rest of the see real good right right
that just it just threw me especially
since I think the zodiacs dead right I
think that he's either dead or all of
them are dead I think most of all the
ones we they're they're ghosts to serial
killers they're uh yeah they're ghosts
serial killers they sure can act ya know
they're terrible oh my god that's awful
yeah I got nothing more yeah work what
that does remember when the Charlie
Brown Christmas tree just flopped over
imagine it that then caught fire and the
fire jumped on a Snoopy and as Snoopy
survived with third-degree burns only to
learn later he had developed cancer
that's how I feel watching this atrocity
- both Christmas and home invasion
movies the only thing with less holiday
cheer would be my new stand-up comedy
album hi I'm new and dumb available now
for streaming services and digital
download I live in a town where Gacy was
declared citizen of the year I know what
I'm talking about if he puts sharp
objects on the ground that he steps on
he's just gonna make a more mad he's
gonna be a very angry clown and before
you ask yes I am wearing a Christmas
onesie the hell no no no disgrace can't
believe the crap I got a deal with when
I'm trying to do stuff and then Here I
am here watching this movie with my time
it's a disaster
no no I'm gonna throw this movie and no
you ready windup for it no while they
make good Christmas movies anymore you
know like a Christmas story - now that's
a good Christmas movie this is the worst
Christmas movie I've ever seen and I've
seen deck the halls with Matthew
Broderick
let's leave the Christmas movies to the
people who know how to do them all right
Santa Claus the Grinch
Madea that's it I'd rather watch
nostalgia critic play Bart's nightmare
don't watch this good I'm
you